I'd like to introduce our
guests this morning, who is, um,
coming to talk to us about mission
to Mars. Um, Laura Parkinson Lark.
I'm a former Googler.
Welcome back.
[inaudible]
all
right,
well, hello. Uh,
many of you may remember me as the Bora
Parkinson though I am now Laurel Arc.
So I was actually a Googler
for about five years. Um,
I worked on them up at team and in Corner
Stan until I left last January to go
to go to Mars, but not really
Mars. We'll get there, uh,
to join high seas mission five as the
mission specialist in it and media.
Slash outreach. Um, my crew
mates had shorter titles.
So let's talk about Mars.
Mars is really far away,
so if at their farthest,
if Mars were at the back of the room,
the moon is somewhere around
the middle of my nostril.
Sorry if my face is the earth
important premise and Martha
at the back of the room,
the moon would be somewhere around the
middle of my nostril and the ISS is
probably so close to my skin. You
couldn't fit a hair between it and me. Um,
so it's much, much farther than
we've sent humans before. Uh,
so this carries a couple,
um, a couple of implications.
So teams on Mars would have to be much
more autonomous then teams on the ISS or
even on the moon.
You know,
you can't have teams of people sitting
in mission control watching their every
move and telling them what to do. They're
going to be operating on their own.
They're going to be much less
in control of mission control.
Um,
so it also means that if you send a
team there and they don't get along or
they're not effective for some reason,
that's really expensive because it's
so expensive to send them there in the
first place. Um, so, uh,
NASA has identified some gaps including,
uh, gaps in what we know about
how to send people to Mars,
including some to do with team
cohesion and to help fill these gaps.
Uh,
NASA funds high seas.
So high seas is basically
a psychological study.
They're looking at team cohesion and
team selection for a long duration space
missions. Um, so to do this,
they run simulated long
duration Mars missions. Uh,
they've got a habitat,
they select crews and put them in the
habitat and collect a bunch of data and
see what happens.
So there have been five crew so far.
Our cruise two through four were
they focused on crew cohesion,
um, for crews five and six.
Um, so I was proof five, uh,
crew six goes into the Hab,
I think in February. Um,
they're focusing on crew cohesion
still and also crew selection. Uh,
and so their goal is to figure out how
to choose and support teams so that
they'll be cohesive and highly
performing in Mars like conditions.
Um, so when we talk about
Margiela conditions, uh,
usually what people talk about
is isolated, confined an extreme.
So that's the acronym you see ice.
Uh,
so the conditions at high seas
are isolated and confined.
They're not extreme
because, um, last I checked,
it's not legal to put human research
subjects in mortal danger. Um,
but the information gained from high C's
can be combined with information from
the ISS or cruise in the Antarctic bases,
um,
or even a missions in Nimmo.
The underground,
the underwater laboratory to get a
holistic picture of how to send teams to
Mars.
So let's talk about the hat.
Um, so this is a picture
of the High Seas Habitat.
Um, so it's on model Loa, volcano
in Hawaii. As you can see,
it's quite a visually
and physically isolated.
It's pretty far off the main road
that is not traveled very much.
I'm way up in the middle of these lava
fields, so not a lot of green visible.
Um,
it's a 8,200 feet elevation,
about 10 miles from the
Caldera of Maunaloa. Um,
did not prove to be a problem for us.
Um,
and it's also chosen for its
geological similarity to Mars.
So actually the Johnson's space center,
Mars regolith Simulant Aka fake Mars
dirt is mind about 20 miles from here.
So, uh, the, the habits self,
it has about 1200 square feet of space,
a thousand feet usable.
And it consists of this dome here
and unattached storage container.
Uh, they're connected by a little
tunnel sort of thing. And, um,
it's all our living space.
We've also got our solar panels that we
get our energy from. Our water tanks are,
you can see our waste water tanks,
slush, evaporation field. Uh,
so this is the setup of the hab
inside.
We've got basically one
big area for living,
working, eating meetings. Uh,
everything we need to do exercise,
uh,
half the desk each.
And then upstairs we've
each got a private room. Um,
studies show that privacy is
important psychologically. Um,
so this is my room so you can see about
enough space for a desk and a bed.
Um, basically everybody gets a
wedge of the Pie in the upstairs.
Yeah.
And of course because we are
okay
on Mars, you have to suit up to
leave and I'll get to that later.
Okay.
Um, so the crew, we're the
lucky ones who got to go,
but there's a whole system of
people supporting the mission.
Um, and in a way, this is part of what's
being studied because the current,
the current paradigm of Mission Control
and a crew that is in close contact all
the time and I'm very much
controlled by mission control,
isn't going to work when you're
as far away as crews will be. So,
uh, we have a team of people there
to assist us called mission support.
Um, it's about 30 volunteers from
around the world. They take shifts. Uh,
we've got a first tier support
that's there to answer questions,
get us information, help us solve
problems, um, for 12 hours a day,
and then someone on 24 hours a day
in case we have a real emergency.
Um, so we also have our, uh,
technical and engineering support.
These are the people who
set up the network, uh,
who actually built the Hab and
can help us. Um, for example, uh,
at one point our water tanks weren't
leveling and it turned out to be an
undocumented one way valve.
So they help us with this sort of issue.
We also have a geologist on staff who
helps us both with our assigned field work
as part of the simulation.
Um,
and just with questions that we
have about the area around the hub,
of course there's um,
mission management to uh,
actually makes sure things run,
gets us water deliveries,
the sort of thing and
the primary researchers.
So there are many studies
going on during each mission.
I'm on us and there's a team of
researchers conducting these,
uh, and then, uh, sort of
external partners. So both, uh,
media like you can see here a couple of
people from the New York Times as well
as, um, our project manager and
local mission support person,
uh, and various external researchers
who some of the crew worked with.
Um,
and I will say with this sort of thing,
it's very important to have
some local mission support. Um,
since practically we,
we are a bunch of people living on earth,
not on Mars and need people to do things
like drive up food every so often and
take away garbage and be there in case
one of us needs to be driven to the
doctor.
In a nonemergency way or something.
So let's see here.
You can see a couple of our engineers are
engineers and the crew inside the hub.
So a major aspect of the mission and of
the isolation was our communications set
up. Um, so at it's farthest, Mars
is about 24 light minutes away.
So this means real time communication
would be impossible. Uh,
so to simulate this,
we communicated with mission
support with our friends and family,
with everybody outside the crew through
email that had a delay of 20 minutes put
in each way. Um, and through
an online tool that also, uh,
both introduced a delay and tracked
our communications for research. Um,
we also had no access to
regular interactive sites
that you might like to use,
like Google,
um,
which can make problem
solving pretty difficult.
So when we needed information,
um,
so with the exception of a few sites like
Wikipedia that we did have access to,
because if you were going to Mars, you
had to download and bring Wikipedia. Um,
so with the exception of that, if we
needed information, say, you know,
I'm running into some issue,
can you search around and see if you can
find someone who has the same problem,
tell me what they said.
I need to describe my problem to mission
support in such a way that they will be
able to search around on my behalf
and get me information back.
So this was really a, an excellent
exercise in clear communication
and it definitely went both ways. So we
had to be clear with mission support.
They also needed to be clear with us.
Uh,
so I remember once early in the mission,
um,
we were quite water constraint.
The company that had delivered water to
the previous crew had on short notice
announced that they weren't willing to
drive up the road to the habit anymore.
And so we had about,
uh,
our tanks were about half full and we
had no water delivery scheduled or way to
get water. Uh, so we were
conserving pretty heavily.
We were down to about two gallons per
person per day and had been there for
maybe a week.
It was starting to get smelly and we
get an email from mission support saying
the water truck is coming and I have
never seen this crew work together so well
or so quickly.
Everybody Sprang into action and got
their showers and got laundry going,
drained the water from the tank so
that we could water the plants. Uh,
and in about a half an
hour, we drained, um, uh,
nearly all of our remaining
usable water from the tanks. Uh,
so 40 minutes later, you know,
20 minutes here, 20 minutes back,
we get a second email that says the water
trucks are coming to see if they can
get up the road.
It was really, it was an
emotional roller coaster that day.
Um, so fortunately for us, they
were able to get up the road.
They weren't there to deliver that day,
but they came a few days later,
we had an emergency tank that lucky for
us was cleaned for the first time just
before mission started.
Um,
so we were able to transfer
some water and, you know,
not run dry.
Um,
but it illustrates the importance
of clear communication in both ways.
When your only method is email.
So I,
we,
the communication delay also
meant that, uh, to a large degree,
our social support had to
come from inside the hat.
So we were allowed as much communication
as we wanted with family and friends,
um,
encouraged shoe email with
them or a transfer video files,
even though I think people didn't end
up taking much advantage of that because
there's really not a lot of
audio privacy in the Hab.
So even something as simple
as, hi, I had a fine day,
how were you?
It feels really awkward when all of your
crew is sitting there and can hear you.
Um, but so it means that the
crew really becomes each others,
family, friends, colleagues.
It is a self contained social network and
all of your support tends to come from
that which makes maintaining
relationships with each other. Really,
really important. Um, so I,
as I tell you about the mission,
I'm also going to tell you
a few conclusions that I
drew that I think may be
relevant to life here at Google. And
this brings me to the first one. Um,
so, uh, what I,
one thing that I found underlaid
a lot of our success, um,
both as a team is maintaining
our relationships as a
group and individually with
each other and in our successes at art
assign tasks or geological field work or
getting data for the researchers,
um,
was our mutual commitment to doing so.
So early in the mission we sat down as
a crew and we wrote a mission statement
for ourselves.
Um,
so of course there are things that we were
supposed to do because it was our job,
but we decided to decide for ourselves
as well what was important to us.
And we decided that as a crew we were
committed to being a cohesive team,
high quality outreach, and getting
good data for the researchers. Um,
so high quality data and this provided
a very important foundation for the rest
of the mission. It meant that
if, you know, if I'm having
an issue with somebody,
I need to take them aside.
Um,
whether it's just that we need to talk
and resolve miscommunication or I need
them to change their behavior in some way,
I know that they're going to be right
there with me solving the problem with me,
working with me,
um,
because we already committed to each
other to do in a really wholehearted,
genuine way.
So I,
and I,
so I encourage teams that need
to accomplish something like,
I mean, not exactly like this, but need
to accomplish something series together,
like probably all of you,
uh,
to come up with principles that you can
all be really genuinely committed to two
together. Um, and I don't mean
goals like, okay, ours, you know,
what are we getting done in the
next month or something. But, uh,
core values like being a cohesive team.
Okay. Back to the, back to the fun stuff.
So I'll tell you a little
bit about have life now. Um,
so as you would need on Mars,
all of our food had to be shelf stable
for three years and somewhat realistic.
Uh, so that meant mostly freeze
dried food cans would be too heavy.
It'd be too expensive to
send their unrealistic.
So lots of bags and cans of
odd looking stuff like this.
I think we have here, uh,
milk freeze dried salmon,
chicken cubes, beef crumbles,
soup and Mozzarella.
So surprisingly it was actually not too
hard to make delicious food out of this.
They smelled really weird, but
when rehydrated are delicious, um,
so I think one of the had favorites
was deep dish pizza for example.
It's turns out it's pretty easy
to make a decent tomato sauce.
You throw in the powder tomato,
the dried onions and just keep doing that
and some spices until you stop up the
water. Um, the cheese, it if you,
if you bake it after rehydrating it sort
of loses its crunchy inner inner core
and um,
it gets a lot more palatable.
The exception to this is
food that we grow. Uh,
so we had a few systems for
doing so in the Hab actually,
mostly not by the window. Um, both,
both because that's ineffective
and unrealistic. Uh,
we had a couple of hydroponic systems,
a crew mate of mine
used to work on Veggie,
which is the system they use on
the ISS for growing vegetables. Um,
so he got them to send us prototype and
he was working with that as well as its
earthbound outreach focused
counterpart growing beyond earth.
So we had those in the Hab and got quite
a bit of produce from them as well as
just some grow lights in the back that
we could grow stuff with. So we had,
not a lot but enough for a bite every
so often of various greens and peas,
beans, even a few tomatoes that
were a, an occasional treat.
I remember once, um, Earl,
my crewmate who works on
Veggie and I were, uh,
we'd harvest it about a month's worth of,
of leafy stuff and we were making a
salad and Jay smelled it from his room.
So upstairs door closed, he comes
out, are you cutting lettuce?
So it really was a treat, but, uh, so, um,
we did not bring all of our food
with us to begin with. Uh, we had,
we probably could have lived off of
what was in the Hab to begin with. Uh,
but we got three or four, what we call
resupplies throughout the mission,
Aka Hab Christmas.
Um,
so you can see here a
pretty typical resupply. Uh,
we've got tomato flakes,
beef crumbles,
I think some strawberries and in the back,
the all important toilet paper.
Um, so at every resupply, uh,
so for the resupplies we'd submit our
requests for what we wanted a month,
about maybe two months in advance,
and then the resupply would be for two,
three months.
So we were planning many months ahead,
but did get to have some input
as far as our taste in food. Um,
if you were actually going to Mars,
the crew would probably know each other
for years ahead of time and would be
able to help plan the food that gets sent.
Um,
but it turned out that for each resupply,
there tended to be
something that we didn't,
didn't budget per
perfectly, um, one resupply.
It was paper towels that we were
really looking forward to. Another,
I think it was onions and once I, it
was bananas. So two crew mates of mine,
we're really looking forward
to the freeze dried bananas.
We'd been out for a month or something.
Um,
and they loved the freeze dried bananas.
So I,
my crew mate and I who were out picking
up the resupply that day, uh, you know,
we get to where it is and there's
a big box and it says bananas.
And so it's 20 pounds of freeze dried
bananas, which for reference the boxes,
maybe this big, like I could fit
in that box. It's a lot of bananas.
So we tell them over the
radio, we got bananas. Uh,
and as we're bringing
them back up, um, it was,
it was dark at the time.
And I see that we have this led strip
in the Hab and they turned it on to be a
rainbow strobe light.
And the Hab was pumping out Gwen Stefani,
the a an a,
there was a lot of excitement
in the hat that day.
So,
uh,
another way in which the mission
was somewhat realistic, uh,
was in our limited resources.
Um,
so these are our solar panels
with very little exception.
All of our energy came from these,
so cloudy days we'd need to
conserve sunny days less. So, um,
if we did,
if we had multiple cloudy days in a row,
we had a backup generator
generator, we could run, um,
keep critical hab systems up and running.
Uh,
and if for some reason we weren't
able to go out, for example,
we had some pretty heavy sustained winds.
At one point we had hydrogen fuel cells
that would kick in as a backup. Um,
so we weren't actually in,
we had lots of redundancy and weren't
in danger of our systems going down or
anything. Um, but mainly our
power was from solar, uh,
which ended up being less
constraining than the water.
Um, so, uh,
since high seas is a psychological study,
they are simulating things,
um, well enough to be
relevant psychologically.
So for example,
our water was limited,
but we weren't actually exercising
recyclers. It came from tanks. Um, so,
uh,
it was sort of up to us to limit our use.
Um, I think possibly,
again, for legal reasons,
they're not allowed to tell us
not to use water. Um, but I,
so we ended up using about five to six
gallons per person per day for reference.
This is about 5% of what the
average American uses. Uh,
so we did this with, uh,
a few methods including,
um, you know, bucket bathing
rather than showering.
So we were allowed eight
minutes of shower per week,
but often chose to use that
in a couple bunches with, um,
a little bit of bathing
between, um, this is,
you can see here our dishes set up.
So we've got our grind bucket,
our soap bucket are rinse
bucket, uh, that we can,
that allows us to do a whole dinners
worth of dishes with only a couple extra
gallons cause we can sort
of move everything left as
we go and reuse the water
as it gets. Or, um,
so it was up to us to come up with
this sort of system to conserve a,
and one important way or thing that we
had that allowed us to do so was that we
had composting toilets.
Um,
so we had a couple of these in the
habit was up to us to keep them happy,
which was important to both their
and our quality of life. Um,
so we turned to them
a couple times a week,
put in microbes and then
empty them once a week.
One of the more glamorous
aspects of living on Mars,
it was actually a somewhat coveted
chore because although it's not super
pleasant, it can sort of end up
being a bonding experience. You know,
you either end up with someone
who's really okay with it
and then that's kind of
fun,
or who's I entertained by
not being okay with it.
And then that's just fun for both of you,
for one of you.
Um,
so I,
it was a somewhat coveted chore because
it took less time than the other chores.
Um,
and was ended up being kind of fun,
at least for me because I
didn't really mind it. Um,
so I, in addition to, uh,
the resource conservation and
the shelf stable food, uh,
we had to exercise quite a bit.
So this was both for our
own health because we're in
this very small space for a
long time. We need to keep our
hearts healthy and such. Uh,
but also because on Mars you would
have to exercise quite a bit, we think,
uh, to maintain your bone density and
muscle mass and also your health since you
would be in a confined space.
So we had about an hour and a half
allocated each data exercise. Um,
I think on the ISS it's even more, it
might be two or three hours per day. Uh,
but so the simulated the time drain and
the energy drain of having to exercise
that much. Um, so lastly, uh,
both for our own psychological wellbeing
and health as a group community,
we had quite a lot of fun together.
So we'd watch movies, play Games, um,
have special dinners.
We had a couple of Hibachi nights where
two crew members would get out the
griddle and um,
marinade some of the beef cubes and then
chop it all up on the griddle and throw
things at each other.
This is a picture of a,
one of our open mic nights. So
we had a couple of these, uh,
we would sort of rearrange the hat
and turned it into a coffee shop,
take out some of the tables that we
used for some of the research tasks and
perform things for each
other. So it was, uh,
it was really up to us to make the,
have a lively social environment.
And that was one of the parts
I enjoyed most about it.
Yes. Yes they are. We
made some donuts. Um,
we had flour and yeast,
which you could argue is more
like two years shelf stable. Um,
but would probably be good enough,
especially if you kept it
in the right conditions. Um,
I also had a sourdough starter for,
uh,
for most of the mission and
then it got too cold for it. Um,
and also I stopped feeding it in one
of these things. Probably killed it.
So I get asked a lot, what do we
do all day? So we're kicked him in.
The stone were pretending to be on Mars.
What's our actual job?
So first and foremost,
we are lab rats.
We are the subjects of
the primary research. Um,
so as part of this we give
spit and hair samples.
These will be measured after the mission,
um,
for stress hormones to study both how
this varies monthly throughout the mission
and how it varies throughout the day.
So I'm on certain days will give several
spit samples throughout the day and
those will be give you the daily rhythm.
And then every month we shave
a little bit of our heads.
So I have bald spot for science now.
Um,
we also wear sociometric badges. So these
measure our proximity to each other.
I only four hours a day,
not all the time. Um,
so these measure our proximity to each
other and the volumes of our voices and
are also connected to, uh,
to heart rate monitors.
So we hear that from this.
They can tell whether we're having an
argument or whether we're avoiding each
other.
Though,
I think they may be more accurately
detecting whether we were playing video
games.
So we also were 24, seven,
a act to watches which are,
which have accelerometers and light
sensors as part of a sleep study. Um,
so in addition to the
actual physical metrics,
we do quite a few team activities.
Um,
so here's one for example.
Uh,
there's sometimes games or things that
we need to do to calibrate the equipment.
Um,
and through these and through
surveys associated with them,
the researchers are measuring our
communication with each other,
our interactions with each other, how
well we're cooperating, the sort of thing.
Um,
I also get asked if we
recorded and we were,
we were asked to record
some portions of our life.
So for example,
all of our meetings were recorded and
they'll be analyzed for, you know,
who's speaking up, who's being heard, um,
how are we interacting?
Uh,
and also all of our I eva data
is both audio and video recorded.
And then we bundle that up and
send it to the researchers.
And the lastly, they get a lot
of information through surveys.
So we did a lot of surveys,
more than a thousand each.
First thing when we wake up,
the last thing before we go to bed,
we fill out surveys.
These are everything from a
self perceived stress to uh,
surveys, asking about how we're
doing, treating us as a family,
to uh,
describe what happened to this week,
what was most difficult
in these different ways.
So that's where a lot of the data
for the study is coming from.
So we also had quite a bit of time
allocated for personal projects. Uh,
so mine,
I brought a drone and I basically
focused on what it could be used for.
So,
uh,
I use ditch to build models of relevant
parts of the area around the Hab.
Um,
used it for a scouting both
to try and find things and uh,
to look at an area without
having to go there first. Um,
this is a model that I built with it.
Um,
and it turns out you can
do all sorts of things.
Once you've got an elevation model,
you can compute elevation
profiles from that slopes,
changes in elevation volumes.
Um,
all kinds of useful stuff. Other people
on the crew we're working, like I said,
on Veggie, I, one person was
working on manufacturing, um,
molecules in a constrained lab
like you might have on Mars.
Um,
useful for things like medicine.
Since one problem about,
or one challenge for long duration space
flight is that a lot of medicine has a
shelf life of less than you'd
probably be out there. Uh,
so being able to manufacture this sort
of stuff in situ is pretty important. Um,
others were looking at, uh, optimizing
our resource usage in the hab sampling,
lava tubes for what might be growing
there, three d printing, a bunch of stuff.
Um, and lastly, we spent
quite a bit of time on Eva.
So Eva stands for extra
vehicular activity.
This is when we suit up and go outside
the hat. Um, but it's not that simple.
So if we want to go outside of the Hab,
uh,
the day before we have a meeting,
we plan what we're going to do.
Um,
we practice it if necessary.
We write up a request and we send it
to mission support. If they approve it,
then the next day, about a half an
hour before we're scheduled to go out,
we gather our personnel, equipment,
batteries, water, whatever.
We need a suit up, get ready, and
we still can't go outside. Um,
because if you were actually on Mars,
the outside pressure on the
inside pressure are very
different and the outside
pressure is not so suitable for humans
and the [inaudible] if you just opened
the door, the people inside would
probably not. Thank you. Um,
so we simulate decompression by sealing
off a part of the Hab and waiting for a
little while. So once we
decompress, we, um, well,
I mean for a defined a little while.
Uh,
so once we decompress
so we can go outside,
we follow the route that we
planned ahead of times. Um,
we are constrained by the time that
we requested. Uh, we come back in,
I,
we recompress and we're still not done
because we need to debrief with each
other. We need to process a lot of
the data from the eva write summaries,
send them to mission support.
Um, so going outside,
although it's quite atonomous
in the actual execution of it,
is still highly controlled as it
probably would be if you were on Mars.
Given that going outside is one of the
more dangerous things you would have to
do a and throughout the whole thing,
we stay in contact with each other of
your radio and are required at all times
to be in contact with the person inside
the Hab who's called Hab calm or ivy for
intro vehicular.
Uh,
so this brings me to the second
thing I'd like to talk to you about,
which is this process.
So we found we had a,
a great number of successful EBS and a
great number of unsuccessful PDAs and
found that the successful ones
were usually do too good, uh,
execution of this process.
And when we had an unsuccessful one,
it was usually because we'd
failed somewhere in here.
So I think usually when people think, oh,
I have something critical I need to do,
I'll plan it and then I'll do it.
Um, but there's more to it than that.
So for example,
once we were,
we were trying to measure a
cross sections of a lava tube,
we were trying to validate a
digital method that weed, um,
that we wanted to use for future tasks.
And so we were choosing cross sections
to measure and that turned out to be
really contentious. When you were out
in the field, um, one person would say,
this is the cross section we need
another would say it's too close to the
opening, there's too much ambient
light here and there's really,
it's not the place to have
a discussion like this.
You need to have had that
kind of discussion before
you go out and when you out.
It's just time for execution. Um, and
we figured out when we got back in,
it was because the different people out
had different ideas of what problem we
were trying to solve with the
data that we were collecting.
So we hadn't done a good enough job
of defining the problem that we had.
Um, another time we were, uh,
we were planning an emergency
route in case we needed to,
to do a simulated evacuation to a
lava tube. So if you were on Mars,
occasionally there are periods of
higher radiation. Um, you know,
the sun releases a bunch of particles
and here we're protected by our
magnetosphere, but on Mars you'd
need to shield yourself somehow.
And one suggestion is that people might
hunker down in a lava tube until it
passes. So we were planning an
evacuation route to a lava tube nearby,
um,
and uh,
because we knew that this sort
of thing might come day or night,
we needed to mark it out in a way that
would be easy to follow at night as well.
So we actually, we went
out ahead of time, um,
requested a night eva and tested the
different kinds of markers we had.
And it turns out that what
we thought would work well,
we had these super shiny pieces of tape
was impossible to see unless you had it
at just the right angle because it would
reflect your flashlight off somewhere.
That wasn't your eyes.
Um,
but we had these little orange flags that
turned out to be super fluorescent and
those worked really well.
So we ended up finding this out
in marking the path with them. Um,
we did a simulated or we requested to
practice at night to make sure that it
worked,
which was one of the odder experiences
because it was one of the times when we
were all outside together. So
usually two out, two in for safety.
Um,
but we had gotten permission to practice
this evacuation and so all six of us
were out with our supplies at night and
I was imagining what someone would think
if they found us six people in a line in
Hazmat suits walking across the lava in
the middle of nowhere.
I, I'd be concerned.
Um, so I think this,
this process applies to,
uh,
any,
any group that needs to
do something critical,
something that needs to
go right the first time.
Yeah.
So we did EBS for a variety of reasons.
Um,
a lot of it was purely operational.
Take down the trash, take down the poop.
This is the, um, the pile that we
had near the end of the mission.
I think the last pickup was
around three months ago. Um,
so this is the sort of stuff you don't
want hanging around in the Hab. Um,
we go down to pick up resupplies I
sometimes check on our water tank,
see how the levels are doing a
run the generator if we need to,
which we did a couple of times.
MMM.
We were also assigned quite a
bit of geological field work.
This is actually the main reason that
we go outside is to collect data of
various sorts. I on the
area around the hub. Um,
so some of it was straight
up measurements. Um,
because of the geological field
work is part of the study.
A lot of it is focused on our teamwork.
While we do it.
The tasks are actually are part
of the control between missions.
So each mission gets the same ones,
which is why I won't tell you
a ton about them. Um, but, uh,
so like I was saying,
a lot of it turned out to be straight up
physical measurements of things around
the Hab. Um, some of it was
mapping the geological units.
So,
you know,
go see where flows intersect
and try and figure out,
you know, what came first, how old is
this? Some of it was pretty qualitative.
Um, so look at things
like this, that I are,
these really weird formations.
You know,
there's this thing on the top of the hill.
And last I checked,
lava flowed like a liquid and
obeyed the laws of gravity.
So how did these weird lumps that
are about this big come to be?
So go look at them and try and deduce
what, how they formed, what happened here.
Um, and some of it was, uh,
more focused on the inside. Take
samples, come in. This is a picture of,
and all of you and crystal and a
chunk of a boy float near the Hab.
Um, we were also working with a team
out of NASA Goddard. So this is,
this instrument is a called a mini LHR
miniature laser Heterodyne radiometer or
something.
Um,
it measures trace gases in the
column of air between it and the sun.
So they were looking at co two
and methane in the atmosphere. Uh,
so this had two purposes. They were
actually using the data from this.
And it was also a study of how we would
communicate with the researchers behind
it to collect the data to fix it.
When things went wrong.
It did at one point get out of alignment
and we were figuring out how to level
it and what might be wrong with it.
Um,
we've got to do quite a few
emergency drills, um, which
tended to be a lot of fun.
And we also got, uh, quite
a bit of freedom to, um,
to go on exploratory vas.
So go out and check out lava tubes are
skylights or I just go see things that
looked like they might be interesting
on Google earth or a that we'd seen in a
drone flight.
And this brings me to the third
thing I'd like to talk to you about.
Um, so this is us in a lava tube.
That was one of my favorite parts.
Um,
so over and over we found that
work that we did for one reason,
whether it was for fun, just because
we thought it might be interesting,
we want it to go there.
Um,
or maybe we were out with
the drone filming just to,
just to film.
Uh,
we'd found we'd find that this work
would be useful in unexpected other ways.
So maybe we'd happened to get footage
of an area that we needed to go for
mission-related purposes later and now
we can actually make a plan with some
knowledge of what it looks like they're,
um,
instead of with whatever we can glean
from Google Earth, which is not much. Um,
or you know,
maybe we've actually been there before.
It's a lava tube that we've
already explored. So for example,
once we mapped a lava tube system
just for fun to try mapping, uh,
but ended up,
uh,
knowing the right amount about it to
use it for an emergency drill later. Um,
so to some extent, I'm preaching to the
choir here, Google with its 20% time.
Um,
but we,
I encourage all of you to continue
what exploratory work you do.
Um,
because in my experience it is very,
it is valuable in unexpected ways.
Um,
and in my opinion that applies to
space flight as a whole as well.
Um,
there have been many,
many unexpected benefits to life on
earth from the space programs so far.
For example, I think there was a,
uh, fuel valve and the shuttle,
maybe you've heard of this, that
turned out to be just perfect for, um,
the time between when you need a heart
and when you get a heart for little kids,
like they hadn't figured out how to make
reliable little valves like that until
they did it for the shuttle and
now they can use them for hearts
anyway.
So I can't tell you too much
about the actual geology tasks,
but I can tell you some about the
various challenges of being on Eva. Um,
so this is me trying to, I think
trying to fit in that hole, um,
which is a bit difficult in these
suits because they're quite bulky, um,
as suits would be.
MMM.
You also had some some visibility issues.
So this was one of the ways in
which having the mini Lhr there,
which was attempted to,
they attempted to build
it for our situation. Um,
but we turned out to have a
lot of challenges with it.
I think this person is
trying to see the screen.
MMM.
And this person is trying
to see an illuminated dot
that is sort of right at the
base of the barrel there. Um, again,
an exercise in communication,
we uh,
this may be relevant to you as well,
but we found videos to be a much easier
way of sending scientific information.
Then written descriptions.
So here we were told that it is
aligned if you see an illuminated dot.
And so we thought there must be an led.
We can kind of squint and
see through the visor.
This thing that looks
like it might be an led.
So I think this person is
trying to see if the led is on.
Turns out the illuminated.is
created by a shadow.
So at the end of the barrel,
there's this little hole.
And if it's perfectly
aligned with the son,
then the son will cast this little spot
right on what is a sensor not in led.
And so when we were looking
for a v illuminated dot,
we were actually just making it go away
by shading the whole thing with our
enormous head.
MMM.
You can see the visibility here.
I can,
I can see so well that I can't
tell my phone is in the picture.
MMM.
And so some of these are relevant to our
suits and some of them are relevant to
actual suits. One of, uh,
one of those things is actual. So
it's, we'll have to be pretty durable.
Um,
this is my suit in the last week or so
with the mission when you were patching
them up. Uh, so you can see
it gets pretty beat up. Um,
and earth lava,
while sharp is still not as sharp as
Mars lava weathering is easier here.
Um, so in case any of you ever built
a space suit, make it really tough.
Um, lastly, I eenie has happened
in a hazardous environment.
No, I'm just kidding. That's not
about a hazardous environment,
although that is my crew mate
at the bottom of a pit. Um,
so one consideration for setups on
eva is the communication system. Uh,
so because it's important
to have communication at
all times between basically
between earth and Mars,
even though it's delayed,
I you will need some way to explore all
of the varieties of terrain on Mars,
especially lava tubes because those are
one of the most interesting places on
Mars as a potential habitable,
habitable area.
Um,
so at the moment I'm relaying to have
calm what my crew mate in the pit says to
me and he's relaying for
the team down the tube. Uh,
and so communication,
something to be solved.
So the mission ended on September 17th.
We were in there for 242 days total.
Um,
six people went in the same six people
went out. So that's a success in my book.
All right. And we built a team
from this group of strangers
and I'm happy to take questions.
Please use the microphones if that's okay.
Thanks for sharing.
Um, so you mentioned that part of mission
five was about team selection. Also.
Can you tell us a little
about the selection process?
Sure.
Um,
so what I can tell you what I
experienced from the selection process.
Um,
so the,
the first step that actually involve
my interaction was a whole bunch of
psychological surveys.
So things like everything from what time
of day you like to be awake to how you
cope with stress. Um, just a
whole bunch of different screens.
Uh, the second part was
an asynchronous interview,
so it was a system where
it asks you questions,
you have something like a minute to
think in, three minutes to record. Um,
and that was the process.
There was six people.
Can you go down into how
goals six people operate you?
Do I pray this single crew of six or
very good broken down into like Tucson
fees?
Was there any hierarchy like sort of
like gene bleed that drive 70 bucks?
Yeah. Um, so I'll answer
your last question first.
We had a commander that was
the extent of her hierarchy.
So commander everyone else. Um, the,
for the most part we found that sort of
formal authority not to be necessary.
We did most stuff by consensus.
The exception was eva where we found
a formal chain of command to be really
important for getting things
done effectively and efficiently.
Um,
so for the most part we operated as in
work for the most part we operated as a
team of six.
Sometimes there would be certain people
who are more interested in different
things and we tend to work on them more.
Um,
but we saw it as our group responsibility
to complete them one way or the other,
whether that was a couple of people that
are interested in volunteer or we all
pitch in.
Um,
socially I think people tended
to break up a bit more. Um,
so we,
we did spend a lot of time as a group.
We also spend a lot of
time in twos and threes.
Thanks for sharing.
Um,
can you talk about the
psychological results?
You said that that was what they
were studying. Have you guys, um,
and I guess they probably haven't,
maybe they haven't released the,
the result of publicly,
but at least like qualitative
qualitatively from your perspective,
like how people changed over the
time that you were there? Um,
the, the short sad answer is no. Um,
both because the research is still ongoing
since the next mission is part of it.
Um,
and because as a participant,
I'm not privy to the
researchers conclusions yet. Um,
they'll publish and probably a couple
of years once the next mission has done.
Um,
I know that personally I think I became
more independent person as a result of
the mission.
Um,
I definitely improved
my interpersonal skills.
Um, but I, I can't say anything
about broader conclusions.
Hi,
thank you for sharing.
It's been really interesting
hearing about your experiences. Um,
I'm curious to know what's next
for you now that you've come back,
what are you up to? What's your next step?
Um, that's a, that's a great question.
I'll let you know.
Do you have any specific interests?
Are you exploring a wide
variety of different, um,
I,
I definitely would like to continue,
continue contributing to space
exploration in one form or another. Um,
whether that's through work,
studying, volunteering.
I was a question about your drone project.
So was that useful because it was higher
resolution than like satellite images
because twin was like shifting on
my list because what a terrain would
potentially be like changing on Mars.
Um,
so for us we found it
useful exactly as you say,
because it's much higher resolution.
Um,
and also because it's
targeted. So, um, right.
I can't say we were successful,
but at one point we tried to search
for a wast water bottle for example,
had fallen down someone's
pants leg and um, we,
we didn't recover it. We did find a Bush
that was surprisingly similar in color.
Yeah.
But mainly because we could,
we could go get images of
what we wanted and they were,
they were much higher resolution,
satellite imagery, the imagery,
and interestingly often easier to spot
things on. Then when we went in person.
Uh, so for example, there was,
there was one feature where it had a I a
shape that was not really noticeable on
the ground because it's sort of in the,
the subtleties of how the rocks fall,
but it's really easy to
spot from an aerial image.
So yeah, it filled the gap
between ground and satellite.
What surprised you most about your time?
Um,
that's a good question.
I have no idea about most.
But one thing that surprised me was how
accustomed I got to the communications
delay.
Um,
so I was expecting it to be weird to
come out in a lot of ways and it ended up
feeling pretty normal except
for instant communication.
So we're so used to, you
know, you send an email,
the person doesn't even
get it for 20 minutes. Um,
and so I'd send emails and get a response
back in two minutes and it felt creepy,
like in the, I didn't know you
were looking kind of way. Um, yeah.
So that surprised me.
How did this experience affect your
relationships with friends and family? Uh,
when earth, so to speak, both
during and after this experience.
That's a good question.
Um,
so I think that the mission was
particularly tough for me in that regard,
um, because I got married about
four months before the mission.
Um,
so
I guess in a way I'm,
I'm still discovering the ways in which
relationships have changed, but it was,
it was definitely a challenge for me
and my husband to figure out how to,
how to be supportive of each other when
being an immediate emotional support or
person to vent to isn't really an option.
Um,
and figuring out ways to stay connected.
So for example,
we had a few movie date night,
so we'd set a time to start a movie
and then send a bunch of email back and
forth during. So it's still delayed,
but if you send enough of it,
it sort of feels like you're chatting.
Hi. Thank you for sharing. Um,
what kind of personal effects read aloud
to bring and kind of on the same note,
uh, what did you miss most when you
got there and now that you're back,
what do you miss most about being there?
Okay.
Um,
so we were allowed to bring two
suitcases of anything except food.
Um, though I smuggled in
some astronaut ice cream,
so I brought a suitcase of clothes,
mostly warm clothes.
I have a suitcase of craft
supplies and a bio Lynn.
Um,
different people made different choices.
I think what I miss the most besides
obviously people while I was there was
probably fruit.
Um,
and I,
I would definitely say I miss my
crew most now that I'm back. Um,
but again, people is kind of a cop
out. So I guess I'd say I miss the, uh,
we had a really a really
nicely scheduled by,
so it was pretty consistent. It was, um,
we had a tool that we use to
communicate what we were doing. Uh,
that meant that every
minute of the day was,
we knew what we were supposed to be
doing. Um, including pre sleep posts,
sleep, lunch, they hit, it was
all scheduled in there. Um,
so I think having that,
that tool and that structure to my day.
Right.
Thank you very much. Laura.
This was fantastic talk. Um,
that's it for questions, but, um,
I assume you're going to hang around
for a little bit of, can run it,
talk to you offline,
and we encourage you to stay for the APE
team coming up next to talk about your
machine learning resource
here in New York.